let's give it Josh everything all you up
my name and I know just just has to do
your office hours at some point so yeah
this is this is this is very cozy yeah
yeah which is a tall group
okay so Hans I invited him to give a
talk on a problem that we're seeing a
lot in manufacturing these days which is
how do you take really complex modeling
and then apply it in real time so they
can get feedback on like the factory
floors or they're working on and these
are really complex multiphysics
simulations that they're working with
tons of course started in a very
different area but now applying it here
in manufacturing and so it's it's a very
neat project take it away boys thank you
the scale and if you're recovering
that's near top and I'm good but this is
someone that everyone knows about me I
will talk a little bit about that and
give you some different examples and
this it's helpful because and and anyone
I guess online however one would
interrupt online they tweet in okay
great
so you're watching the so I'll try to
keep it general and please do interject
and ask those questions and Peter I
originally thought this was a 20 minute
talk and so I'm covering more than just
the manufacturing my actually going
through a bunch of different things to
the other models yeah very good
all right so I'm hamster Hanson I'm in
the applied numerical algorithms group
and if you've heard other talks from
Lawrence Berkeley you realize we work in
very large distributed teams often all
over the country in the world
so I have a laundry list of people that
have helped me with various pictures of
things you're gonna see today so the
challenge of accurate fast multi scale
multiphysics simulations a lot of things
they're about multi scale in this case
means you might have things at a
thousand times or even a million
time's different physical scales in
space or time and multiphysics in this
case means you don't just care about one
thing like heat transfer you might care
about heat transfer and chemistry fluid
flow heat transfer and chemistry
radiation heat transfer fluid flow and
chemistry right and that list
you know if you think of the physical
world around us that list is as long as
you want to make it and the whole point
of making science possible is to be able
to make the simplifying assumptions that
get you a point where something is just
feasible to be both novel and possible
to compute so that's that's pretty much
what this this talk is about and that's
a moving target somebody could be
brilliant with mathematics and all of a
sudden something is computable somebody
could be brilliant with modeling and all
of a sudden something is simplified
enough where it's computable computers
can get 10 times faster in 10 years
which we have seen for sure if not more
and all of a sudden something that
wasn't computable before in any
reasonable amount of time can be so
those are the trade-offs I'm going to
talk about today so I'm also a little
bit of a contrarian I'm warning you so
I'm going to show you kind of
classically what you might call a pretty
movie a lot of science talks start with
things like this this is actually a
shallow-water equations which is
basically modeling the Earth's surface
as if it were a single layer that was
all moving in unison you can use this
for example for vorticity dynamics in
the ocean it's a simplified model for
the atmosphere this is a particular
simulation which is showing adaptive
mesh refinement these patches here are
where computational resources are being
concentrated I'll play it one more time
the reason I threw this up front with no
context or history or anything else is a
lot of science talks start with pretty
pay pictures or computational
simulations that are these dynamic
movies and you have no idea if they're
right you have you know if you're an
educated person in this field you can
say all right well that looks like a lot
of things moving around and maybe
complex dynamics and I see some
interesting features here and there
so part of my point with the talk today
is that I think when people start doing
multiphysics they gloss over all of the
background and thought that goes into
simplifying things to the point where
you can actually compute them this is a
completely inappropriate model for the
ocean unless you're looking at something
very specific like a tsunami wave
propagating across the Pacific Ocean so
I'll talk a little bit about that model
for example but it also highlights how
you can create these discretization x'
where for example each of those cells
there would maybe be 50 to 100
kilometers on a global scale
that's pretty coarse these finer ones
are down at 5 kilometers resolution
which is about the limit of
computational throughput for ocean
simulations today on a global scale so
this is just in a nutshell an example of
how you can go across those different
scales factors of 10 factors of 100 and
magnitude simplified physics simplified
environment and pretty movies but is it
right or not as the question so what
what challenges do we see in multi scale
physics for example so we have these
computational science goals of trying to
provide a high fidelity or good answer
and so asking the question are we
solving the right mathematical problems
on the computer is a really important
starting point and then you also have to
ask yourself again all right so I have a
mathematical model I'm applying it to a
specific problem like it's tsunami am i
doing a good job or have I
oversimplified things or they're things
I just really don't know about for
example what does the bottom of the
ocean look like if you'd asked that a
hundred years ago people really had no
clue today we know we do and we can get
ever higher resolution of it but that
resolution costs computer time and other
things
that's great position thanks for coming
I actually included one of your results
in here
the second question for these multi
scale physics trade offs is accuracy so
if we've got a representative
mathematical problem are we doing a good
job of actually solving that
mathematical problem in a way that is
both feasible and that we have
confidence in our numerix for example
and are we certain that the data and the
parameters were using are those valid
enough that we can actually say yes this
result is now a valid multiphysics
simulation correctly computed to compare
to the real world so fidelity accuracy
and the last one is efficiency if all
those things are perfect and we still
can't get an answer out in three weeks
then maybe that's not a real-time system
you want to work with so for example if
we were to take a model and do tsunami
warnings right you have to be able to
turn it around within hours to make sure
that you understand the impact of
something across the Pacific Ocean for
example or to understand where you might
provide warnings or evacuate people or
things like that and we're still not at
that point with weather we're still not
at that point with things like natural
disasters and we're just getting to that
point I think with manufacturing
problems that are much more within our
control and so I have an example of one
of those but the other thing we have
going for us is that we have computers
that are just growing so rapidly it's
crazy
so one of the things that our group does
is to try to take advantage of every bit
of computing power we're given by these
big investments in supercomputing
facilities like nurse got Pier at LBL
technologies like many core processors
vectorization GPUs things like that
they're all trends that are basically
given us a hundredfold in computing
power just in the the past 10 years and
then the last question on that so we got
one simulation done in the reasonable
amount of time do we have enough
simulations to build up our confidence
levels and one of the things that we see
a lot is is hero calculations where you
just push through the calculation you've
got it done I simulated an earthquake
great what does that mean in terms of
earthquakes in general did you do enough
statistical evaluation of the weather to
be able to say something about climate
instead of just a single weather event
things like that so I see our
computational science challenge
for these kinds of problems as this a
just continual trade-off between solving
the right problem solving it correctly
and solving it fast enough to the
answers are useful and at a resolution
and accuracy that we care about so the
rest of the talk basically fills in
those gaps so here's an example of some
work I've done with colleagues up in the
the basically the Environmental Sciences
Division and up here for example this is
a classically high resolution simulation
of climate on earth that's what it looks
like in terms of the mesh that you use
to discretize things and you can start
adding higher resolution things over
California if you want to start for
example picking up mountains watersheds
even just the coastline
at resolutions like this San Francisco
doesn't exist the bay doesn't exist you
don't see it right the Coastal Range
doesn't exist the Sierras are a small
blip that goes about thousand meters up
so when you do these really coarse
simulations you get the fidelity of a
global simulation accuracy wise but
you're missing out on the things you may
really care about like how much of this
rain is going to end up being water for
us in the summer for next year so some
techniques you can use this is a
different kind of adaptive mesh
refinement that's just static but it's
it's adapting around the things you care
about in this case watersheds the peaks
of the Sierras and the difference
between a 55 kilometers Ellucian and a
seven kilometer resolution in terms of
the errors that's the red and blue in
these plots is huge basically the
topography doesn't exist at the
computable resolution so you have to be
smart mathematically and algorithmically
and physically to get it to the point
where you can do something that is
actually more accurate for what your
interest is in the scientific questions
so that's an example and one of the
reasons that this historically has been
a problem is that it wasn't computable
to do these high resolution simulations
so you're just hoping for good growth
statistics and trends Mountains for
example are represented by these
jiggedy-jaggedy train following meshes
for example and you can show by looking
at the statistics from those previous
meshes that for example 1500 meters in
error between a 55
kilometer simulation and a seven
kilometer simulation you know this this
binning of errors basically the only
thing you can barely see the green here
in this but seven kilometers is closest
to reality it's still not great but
you're completely missing the peaks of
the mountains and it's changing with
every simulation so if you had a series
of these simulations and you're trying
to draw statistics from three or four of
them in the series you've got no hope
when you've got this shape messing with
your mesh messing with your solutions
its computable which is nice and it's
fast but it doesn't give you the
accuracy that you want so that's just
one example from climate and and weather
and I was really disappointed to miss
the NOAA talk yesterday I hope that I
hope that was kind of in the same vein
about computing power I will do that so
here's another example
so this compares whether we're solving
the right physics or not mg1
is named after Morrison gentlemen who
were some physicists that started
talking about all right if we have to
model rain and clouds at a global scale
what is cheap enough for us to calculate
on yesterday's computers and so they
came up with this algorithm basically
says if it's gonna rain it dumps it
lands on the ground directly underneath
that cell and that's good enough at
least then we have rain coming out of
the atmosphere and we have evaporation
going back up over the oceans more
recently although it's still not in many
global models they've done a second
version of this we're like you know what
rain doesn't instantly puddle on the
ground you have to let it drift it can
move horizontally with the wind so we
have to be much more careful about its
interaction with elevation and mountains
and other atmospheric phenomena so here
again is this really course simulation
at 55 kilometers and the statistics are
completely wonky if you look at the peak
here from observational data we're
missing all of that and that's primarily
because the rain is puddling and there
are no mountains right so even though
you improve the physics model you're at
a resolution where it doesn't really
make any difference it's not going to
help you have systematic errors in your
work this was with my colleagues
machines you and
island roads just a simple doubling of
the resolution which means eight times
the computational cost for this model
gets much better statistics and you can
see now we actually start to have things
in the 2500 to 3500 meter elevation we
actually have mountains again with a
simple eight times improvement
computational cost this one is another
factor of eight cost but because we're
being smart about where we refine over
California the statistics are improving
for the things we care about and the
global cost if we were to do that
simulation globally it would be weeks on
a supercomputer and it's just not
feasible anymore but because we're doing
it regionally just over California we
get better and better statistics so
finally we're starting to see a
separation between the old way of doing
things down here which doesn't match
these statistics very well at all and
the new way where the rain and the snow
actually end up where they belong and
now we can start talking about water
resources yes for the temporal domain
these are seasonal averages basically
right so because in California we get
all of our rain and snow in a three to
four month period basically no this is
just static this is just trying to get
mountains yeah and especially one of the
things we're interested in is which side
of the mountain does it fall on because
it matters whether Nevada gets the water
or we do right so getting those
watersheds resolved in getting the
altitude of those watersheds so we know
if it falls as water or snow is a very
important thing so this is an example
where we finally after let's say West
Asian maybe 25 years from mg 1 to MT to
15 15 years we're solving the right
problem and we just have the
computational problem to solve it at the
right resolution and we're finally
starting to get the right answers so
that's quite an accomplishment for the
field but I would have hate to have been
in the audience feeling confident about
my answers 15 years ago it just wasn't
feasible this is a work from my
colleagues paper using a regional
forecasting model called Wharf driven by
real data
which is basically re-analysed satellite
data called ends up purses a that same
variable resolution model which I will
call untethered it's basically it's
simulating year after year after year
without any data input into what's
actually happening it's just being
driven by the previous global climate
model and look at the uncertainty here
this data is actually from satellite and
even though we're using that to drive
the model it's getting something not too
far off from the observational model
although you know this is satellite so
you're not entirely sure but it's in the
right ballpark range and if you look at
the variation of this freerunning or
this non data-driven solution look at
the huge variation across these
resolutions and I can't say there's a
trend to converge from 28 to 14 to 17 or
from 14 to 17 maybe so I still think
this is the kind of open question of we
might be doing physics simulations
correctly but are we incorporating data
in the best way possible and then can we
draw a long term statistics from those
kinds of simulations that are
freerunning so I think this is still a
very open area of discussion we might be
able to get weather right for the next
week but I still feel that for the long
term we're having a very hard time
getting climate and one of the things
you can see is that what we're doing is
is adding resolution solving the best
physics problems we can but we're still
missing something about the climate
statistics that's undermining our
ability to do all the mathematics
correctly so so here's a potential
solution we saw that jagged terrain
following mapping maybe we keep things
smooth maybe we map it in a way that's
you know our numerical answers are
better but we do some representation of
the real actual topography of the
mountains and now this might be able to
get us certain properties like that's
just like mathematical expression for
conservation and mapped grids so that
you make sure that rain the clouds
things going in and out you get those so
here's an idea that I'm pursuing where
this stays the way it is and the mesh is
actually think that Corson's and there
have been some other authors who've had
some good luck with this for for tsunami
modeling this is somebody at No
named he foot Alistair ad Croft there
and he's he's the head of the ocean
model development and he's done some
great work where you do these super
high-resolution tsunami modeling so you
probably don't recognize it but that's
sri lanka that's south india so this is
the Andaman what was it 2004 tsunami
from the earthquake in Indonesia and you
can see these are the gross things in
terms of magnitude and the waves that
are going to be pounding sri lanka and
this is an incredibly coarse resolution
i think this is a 64 x course which
means it is a thousand times cheaper to
compute but he's getting the peaks he's
getting the wavelengths to some extent
this is garbage probably in noise but
maybe it's enough to indicate well at
least that region needs to be under
tsunami warnings right so here's an
example of how i'm sorry there it is so
2 feet by 30 feet roughly 16 times so 16
cubed is still a thousand so basically
he's come up with an approach where he
can modify the way the bathymetry of the
ocean and the coastline are represented
and still get decent answers out and
this is the kind of thing you need for a
real-time system response right if
you're gonna do tsunami warnings you
have to do something that's that's
simple enough to run multiple scenarios
in a very tight timeframe so the way he
did this was to basically instead of
this which is the typical ocean modeling
approach or this one which is a kind of
slanted slightly better approximation of
what could be a very jagged ocean bottom
he basically asked the question well the
point of the ocean bottom is to inhibit
flow and damp flow and so he came up
with a very simple model for what the
bottom of the ocean would look like if
it were represented coarsely and that's
how he got such great results so that's
an example of what i would say a reduced
order model that makes the problem
computable that retains the best aspects
of a high resolution model and he's done
this all without adaptive mesh
refinement if you added something like
adaptive mesh refinement to this just
for the front waves then you could get
more computational gains from it as well
it's also I think a great opportunity
for satellite observations
machine learning to start deducing
reduced order models for us what is the
nature of the model we should be solving
in order to do a better job at course
resolutions because I can brute force
the fine resolution job all day and
spend weeks and months running
simulations at nurse but I would hope to
then take that data and maximize its
value in terms of educating ourselves
around what's a course solution that's
worth doing that was one example so let
me circle back fidelity are we solving
the right problems do we have
mathematically reasonable
representations if we're careful about
them and if we put some thought into
them and really really challenge the
assumptions and then the question have
we oversimplified things or relied on
uncertain assumptions we absolutely do
that routinely and that's where I think
the field needs to have a lot of
intellectual honesty in order to make
sure that we're doing a good job with
that so on to question of accuracy so
here's an example of something we do in
our group which are called cut cells
where you have something like that
really complex terrain in this case it's
a very smooth interface and you run it
across your relatively coarse mess mesh
nice thing about this is that's the San
Francisco Bay Area bathymetry for
example you can do some very good jobs
with rugged coastlines I can get this
down to whatever resolution I want and I
can still put it in this form where I'm
guaranteed that water flowing into the
bay ends up flowing out of the bay
conservation is what we call that so
these kinds of natural conservation laws
are things that come out of physics and
you want your reduced order models and
you want your simulations to respect
those kinds of aspects of things the
other nice thing about this is if you're
trying to do that adaptive mesh
refinement technique you can you can
reduce the domain of dependence of your
mesh to just locally what you're
refining if any of you have worked with
finite element codes before they're
really good one of the biggest hassles
if you wanted to mesh complex things
I'll just skip forward to the picture
here for a second I'll come back to this
if you wanted the mesh complex things
like this like for example that's a
nuclear core reactor with spinners and
mixers that's the old San Francisco
skyline before the Salesforce Tower
corals the bay other complex geometries
this is a x-ray tomography scan of
crushed calcite that one of my
colleagues in our group has done and
he's doing full 3d reactive simulations
multiphysics multi scale on these
domains in order to try to get an
understanding of how reactions happen
inside of a subsurface carbon storage
questions so just to kind of go back to
what you want out of these kinds of
schemes conservation it's got to
represent physics accuracy that was the
point that I was trying to make which is
that if you calculate a solution you
look great my solver converged or it
looks about right or whatever those
kinds of thumb in the air eyeball norms
are that's one thing but it's worth
putting in the extra effort so you're
not deceived and I'll give you an
example of how the deception can happen
consistency so free string preservation
accurate fluxes these are all concepts I
know we've got a very diverse audience
here but basically you want it to have
similar physical characteristics to the
system you're modeling when water flows
if nothing gets in its way it more or
less flows in a straight line or it's
stable if it's under a certain reynolds
number of those kinds of questions
stability is just a question for meshing
and and how we deal with small cells I
won't get into that simplification so
the last point I made on efficiency for
these kinds of algorithms is you want it
to be as regularly structured because
computers like regularly structured
calculations they're best at those our
newest supercomputer Cori phase two has
9,000 processors each of Wick which
expects its cores sixty-eight of those
per chip to get precisely eight doubles
that it can chew through like an
assembly line to do a calculation if we
start breaking that up with unstructured
calculations and looking down neighbor
lists and things like that from a
compute
standpoint we've wasted probably 50% or
more of the cycles of the supercomputer
so we design our algorithms to not only
do the right thing in terms of accuracy
in mathematics but to make sure that we
get low memory vectorizable
descritization x' in most of our
computation I won't go into the rest of
those so here are some examples of how
people do these kinds of complex
geometry cut cell approaches one of my
collaborators at Duke has done something
called extended finite element methods
where you have a typical unstructured
finite element mesh but you do these
intersections there are some work done
for very complex thin body domains other
ones where you have these domains of
dependencies and something called a
immersed boundary methods where you're
approximating the forces based on how
those interfaces interact some
colleagues down in UC Santa Barbara do
complex multi physics problems like
Stephan problems where you have a phase
change in a moving boundary and one of
the real questions is if you have a
phase change you want to conserve the
energy liberated in the latent heat from
those kinds of things so these kinds of
problems are very interesting for
material properties and for asking
questions about crystal growths and
those kinds of things again
manufacturing wise these are really
important questions about how do you do
moving boundaries accurately but yet
cheaply enough that you can modify a
process as it's evolving like if you're
doing chemical vapor deposition or
things like that so here's an example of
one of my colleagues who's doing great
work in using a discontinuous galerkin
method the reason I'm putting this up
there is that you can see that the error
that he's getting looks very erratic but
if that's off in the sixth or seventh or
eighth digit that's okay that's a good
solution right this colleague here a
former postdoc of ours who's now at NASA
and doing some good work there too I
can't tell if that's a good answer or
not this is for aeroacoustics around
landing gear on
on a body now granted you can look at
frequency content you could look at you
know what's the energy spectra of this
turbulent flow and things like that this
is a smooth problem this is not a smooth
problem right so asking the question
around how accuracy and stability of the
numerix and the computations of these
things interplay is a really an
important question some people will do
work just to try to kind of limit their
algorithm to the places where it's
stable others will push it to the
boundary and say it's unstable but it's
getting into the right accuracy range so
those are some questions there I think
I'll skip this but basically these cut
cells there are lots of ways of going
after the small cell problem which leads
to stability issues we've come up with a
novel way of doing it which is a little
bit more mathematical but this gives you
a sense of how complex some of these
boundaries can get when you're dealing
with things like moving crystal
interfaces or those complex
terrain-following
or getting rid of those complex
terrain-following meshes so one of the
things that's interesting about accuracy
in this case is the question if you have
a really smooth problem in a really
smooth solution do you trust the answer
for this well we can get ten digits of
accuracy on a on a laptop with this kind
of a simple problem with certain
boundary conditions
there's a kid outside playing basketball
so it's kind of the sick thanks Peter
I'd go out and play with him if I didn't
have to talk for the next half hour so
in this case though this is just another
very simple geometry but the geometry is
kinked in these corners in fact if you
look at it it's mathematically it's a
well posed problem and I could apply a
12th order accurate method to this but
if you do the analysis on this the
mathematics doesn't like the kink the
interface there although it's well posed
as soon as you discretize it you're
introducing discretization errors and
then your your solver is solving a
modified problem which is not correct
anymore so basically I went from ten
digits of accuracy my solution down to
two if I'm lucky and if I beat this to
death with computational power it's not
going to improve very much beyond that
so I know this is a huge chart of
numbers but this just shows you how you
get two digits here and you're working
really hard in three dimensions that
would have been a you know 10 to the 9th
degrees of freedom but it's it's a huge
resolution improvement with an old
algorithm that we've used and it's not
even converging right now our current
algorithm that we're using is much more
higher accuracy and it's still not
converting to so you see this kind of
problem you get a pretty picture and you
see two digits of accuracy okay I'm done
right that's as good as I can get well
it's not true because from an accuracy
standpoint if you look at it
mathematically you can do all of these
modifications where you can say kinks in
the geometry should be smoothed out to
some relative level of accuracy as my
computational solver there are
mathematically clever ways of doing that
with malla fires and smoothing functions
and when you do that not only did I
improve the old method where I'm getting
you know five digits with a billion
points but my really good method gets to
that point extremely coarse resolutions
right so look at that error versus that
error at basically 30 squared times so a
thousand times the resolution a thousand
times number of
it's fewer so my point in putting this
out here is that pleather math clever
mathematics doesn't get you very far
unless you actually understand the
problems apply it to the right kind of
problem chase it down work with it and
this algorithm here is extremely fast on
supercomputers because it's organized in
a way where you use the processor as
much as possible before communicating
memory or or bytes or other things
there's another example of accuracy
winning out in the end here's another
one kind of mathematical theory wise if
you don't do the right thing for the
stability of the algorithm you end up
with this really noisy representation of
the differential operator this is
supposed to be a very smooth laplacian
which is what's over here you have to do
a very specific way of looking at the
least-squares system in order to get
this smooth behavior which more closely
mimics the physical system as suppose
something which if you just look down
here in this course range is about the
same or correct but as soon as you try
to apply it at scale all your frequency
content is just garbage there's another
example of this this would be for pure
advection these are classic algorithms
that people use that have decent
accuracy that second order act is fourth
order accuracy this is a representation
of the Fourier symbols of this and this
has a 2 Delta X mode so basically you
can introduce plus minus noise then
people start fixing those up with
filters they start adding extra
resolution and filters that course and
things there all kinds of tricks that
people play well if you're good with the
mathematics you can get rid of that 2
Delta X mode and smooth it out and even
kill it and if you're really good with
your mathematics and put in some
computational work you can get something
that's behaving almost like the
mathematics would say it would in a pure
kind of thyroid Fourier sense so you
know kind of back to this question of
accuracy
we picked a mathematical problem we've
tried not to oversimplify it for our
physics problem now we're asking
ourselves did I solve that problem well
and again if you're careful and
realistic and you really scrutinize and
don't just take things at face value you
can do a good job with that and it takes
a lot of testing to build up that level
of confidence just in these simple
mathematical problems when you get to
multi physics problems now you have to
tease apart every little bit and there
are much more complicated interactions
and coupling so this last question of
efficiency I'm going to highlight one
particular software technology there are
other things going on are there any
questions on Twitter today's question
that just generically I was gonna say
that little terzian was what about
running a series of simulations say you
know this or whatever your weather over
the state of California and then using
machine learning to help you interpolate
between different you know you could
imagine earthquakes occurring at
different locations and then using
machine learning to interpolate between
to you know quickly say oh here's years
you know what it would happen if it was
a magnitude 7 at this location rather
than the two weights that I ran
so basically limited number of
simulations and using machine learning
to fill in the space in between them so
high dimensional interpolation is what
that gets called sometimes I think and I
think it depends very much on whether
you can expect the problem to be
continuous so let's go with the
earthquake example if I started off with
a problem that was coarse and I'm moving
to one that is finer then there was
information that the machine learning
algorithm will never see right so the
interpolation might not even be in a
valid range because it's just starting
with bad information so I tried to train
something that's recognizing images of
people starting with images of plants
right you might get lucky
but most the time it's not going to
happen I think the use of machine
learning for that kind of filling in the
simulation experiment is much better
when you have these expensive brute
force but correct models and maybe
that's what you're seeing in in
astrophysics and cosmology which is that
all the models are high resolution and
correct but there's so much data it's
impossible to try to analyze it in all
those dimensions and machine learning is
chewing through that so that would be my
guess I've also seen good work where
people will say my brute force
simulations
I know solve the right problem they
solve I'm sorry they solve the problem
I've given correctly but it's not
matching observations use machine
learning to find where that gap is most
likely right so what was the assumption
I made that doesn't fit the observation
as well as I would like and then one
other question was the underlying
multiphysics models that you have
there's some uncertainty in how you
parameterize things how do you flush
that out through a simulation yeah so so
if you pick constant parameters for
example and you have analytic solutions
you're happy right you know you can
match those and when you get a good
answer and it's numerically conversion
things work well when you have uncertain
parameters in fact the the chemistry
example I'm going to bring up next or
those those cloud examples you can try
to bracket it and do a bunch of
simulations in those ranges you can try
to run ensembles and ask if the
ensembles match like the work that we
were doing with the California snowpack
and rainfall but that's kind of open
question right
okay and you wanted me to stop at 20
after right yeah okay so now I want to
get into efficiency so you know we can
throw all the physics in the world and
all the resolution of the problem and
take the smallest possible time steps at
the level of atomic interactions and it
will never finish so what's the point so
we have to figure out that sweet spot
between what's computable and what's
actually scientifically interesting and
or reasonable and then finally we can't
just do these hero runs did we actually
get enough statistics in our ensemble to
actually have confidence in our solution
now so I wanted to show a little bit of
of how the geometric variation in these
things like here's an interface that's
being represented in some work by my
colleague Robert say who's doing great
stuff right now where he's going to have
to do all the geometric variations of
these surfaces in order to do an
ensemble big enough for all of his work
but notice how in most of the domain
he's expressed something that looks like
an efficient grid data structure and
he's just making exceptions to that
structure and near the boundary so even
if he does move this a couple of cells
maybe every couple of time steps in
order to evolve the interface and do the
right physics you still for the most
part got a regular structure in his
calculation there are other examples of
this they're not really worth going into
but basically people will bend over
backwards to do a one dimension lower
more expensive calculation and retain a
higher dimensional regular calculation
that they know they can optimize like
crazy that means by the time you get up
to a thousand processors maybe only a
hundred are responsible for these
irregular calculations maybe you can
distribute that hundred processors worth
of work across 200 processors and it
goes twice as fast if you're lucky
depending on how you design things so
even though multi physics and multi
scale has a lot of irregularity in it
and I'll show you physics irregularity
in a second you can do things to try to
modify that here's another example for
hyperbolic problems where this is again
my colleague David Trevor ditch at LBNL
where he's got this cylinder packed it's
it's meant to be a reactive cylinder
where he's got it packed with spheres
and he's pushing gas through it he's
asking about the reaction dynamics on
the surfaces of those spheres and one of
the things about the mixing of the gases
and the temperature and other thing
that's going on here is this is kind of
happening everywhere but if he only
cares about the reaction he can focus on
this area here if he only cares about
the final pressure maybe he doesn't add
any resolution here you know in general
he's going to focus on the things where
the physics are most interesting in
determining the final state of the
system or the quantity of interest
you're looking at so even though this is
a fairly complex gas flow plus diffusion
of heat and species plus the chemical
reactions going on they're running on a
hundred thousand cores it's still going
to have all these different aspects you
have to focus the effort in specific
parts of the domain where those things
are happening here's another example of
shock dynamics you can't see it very
well here but these boxes are the
adaptive mesh refinement of a shock
hitting a sphere and then just capturing
the areas where the fluid flow is not
kind of constant or background so you
can see this entire wedge here of
adaptive mesh refinement around the
boundary of the reflected shock off of
the sphere and also trying to capture
the dynamics on the surface of the
sphere which could involve things like a
boundary layer or viscosity
we've applied this adaptive mesh
technology in our group to a couple of
different problems for moving boundaries
I've done this work where if you wanted
to do for example wave energy conversion
and you wanted to look at free ocean
surfaces and what the pressure fields
are and how could you tap into those
pressure fields to try to drive a energy
converter that could take that that wave
motion and turn it into electricity well
in order to do that you need highly
accurate solutions at the surface that
propagates smoothly down an interior and
then that turns into a real-time control
algorithm for this multiphysics system
so I've got the ocean dynamics physics
right what is the spectrum of waves how
often do we know that we get different
kinds of waves we have the control
algorithm for the wave carpet which
isn't in this so when I see different
kinds of waves coming how am I gonna
modify my system without having to do
these simulations in advance to have a
reduced model to be able to control
these kinds of algorithms correctly and
then last what maximizes our optimizes
the power take-off for these kinds of
calculations up here is a colleague of
mine Dan Martin who's doing modeling of
the Antarctic ice sheets and that little
region there has four or five layers of
adaptive mesh refinement to try to
capture where that ice sheet it's what's
called a grounding line it's the last
spot where it's supported by the land
which could be under the water right so
you can try to figure out how rapidly
the ice sheet is gonna move based on
these incredibly long time spans of you
know hundreds of years basically so in
this case it might not be a real time
control loop but when you think about it
we're driving this ice sheet model with
all these sensitivities on the
atmospheric temperature how much is it
going to snow in Antarctica what's the
average temperature over periods of the
next 20-30 hundred years we're have to
run gazillions of simulation scenarios
in order to try to figure out what
percentage of those scenarios will
actually accelerate the ice sheet flow
and then cause sea level rise for
example right or is there any sea level
rise at all do this or not so those are
questions where the efficiency of this
calculation is really really important
you cannot use a uniform mesh on
arctica and expect to get it done in
your lifetime so he's done this adaptive
mesh refinement just for these
particular glaciers and can attack them
one at the time in a very adaptive way
that uses the the process the computers
efficiently to do it and you know lastly
GCM here is is global climate models
this is some work that I'm still
wrapping up on what you would do if you
wanted to take that shallow water vortex
model and make it much much higher
resolution and actually be able to track
for example tropical cyclones high
resolutions that we can't do today like
a kilometer but making sure to capture
the global context of flows and things
like that
one of the problems that we have with
tropical cyclones and other kinds of
dynamics is that what's computable at a
global scale is absolutely infeasible in
terms of its scientific value you might
get some statistics out of it but
they're mostly short-term and in fact
tracking hurricane paths is still a very
open challenge I don't know if the NOAA
folks talked about that at all but
that's a huge multiphysics problem or
you have surface temperatures you have
the previous tropical cyclone stirring
up the ocean and changing the amount
available energy for the next tropical
cyclone that might pass over in a few
days these are complex multi scale multi
physics problems and they require really
good numerical algorithms and again this
question of feasibility and what you can
compute and what you can't so we have
other examples of shock dynamics and
this is an abduction diffusion test
problem and things like that where you
know reactions in this domain allow you
to concentrate just the extra
computational effort on these small
regions where it matters the most like
what I calculate cloud cover and things
like that on the rest of the globe when
I'm simulating a tropical cyclone
probably not well I can calculate only
where things are the steepest gradients
or the highest values are the most
important for my scientific goals and
leave the rest of the simulation at
relatively coarse resolutions and work
on that so again the efficiency of these
algorithms comes from some software
investments that we've been making over
the past 10 to 20 years some smart
collaborations with scientists to know
where we concentrate on the
on the physics and what physics needs to
be included to get a decent answer and
then on the numerix to make sure that we
get the most out of every aspect of the
computational systems that's possible so
this is the it's just a simple example
from this manufacturing project we have
this cool thing called a clip process
where they illuminate with ultraviolet
light into this resin liquid resin and
they draw out this solid part which can
be as complicated as a mesh they're
actually making dentures now to down to
I think a 100 micron resolution and the
problem is is that they can only print
these things as fast as their current
models allow and it's a real-time system
right every part is going to have a
template and that template is going to
be projected and created on the fly so
we've helped them come up with a
chemistry model that's a reduced order
model to some extent the spans from this
10 micrometer layer where the reactions
are happening the fluid flow this is
just a model fluid flow and then the
final part shape so they can improve
their tolerances they can do a better
job with their reactions and the
ultimate goal is to hope to be able to
do that in a real-time basis where we've
given them a reduced order model they
can use to adapt to how the parts are
being printed they want to draw it fast
and are willing to accept a lower
tolerance use this part of the algorithm
if they want to be extremely precise and
make sure they don't get any tolerances
outside of their their design goals then
you do a different approach so this is
basically how we start building it up
though this is a reaction model for
example if you had the ultraviolet light
just in this region and it's consuming
oxygen and it's got this conversion
where it's the polymers going from
basically a inhibited monomer into one
that's actually going to solidify into
the part and it starts behaving like a
solid part and if you look at the
numerix for this you know basically all
this part we don't need to do any
reaction calculations out here so
immediately if you just ballpark it in
3d from from an eyeball norm we could
save a factor of 10 and our computation
efficiency by just recognizing the
physics is only happening in certain
regions and then building that smarts
into our modeling another thing is the
rate of chain
to this you know this this shoots up
initially and then it slows down shoots
up then slowed step slows down so those
gives us opportunity to change kind of
the dynamics of the timing of things and
then this is the last one which is a
little tricky which is that this is a
mesh imprinting so basically as you're
doing a calculation like this where you
have a reaction that happens every time
you kick over some concentration value
you'll get these spurts which are very
unphysical in terms of how these
reactions progress when really what you
want is something that's kind of
smoothed out and more accurate even at
coarse resolutions so one of the things
we're working on here is a reduced order
model that will make sure that any of
our numerix that are under resolved kind
of like that tsunami simulation still
get us a good answer and that's that's
work in progress as well but it's really
important for these guys because all of
their complexity comes from the fluid
flow which they can't really observe and
what they know about the chemical
reaction which you're very confident
about in a static kind of chemistry
laboratory environment but they're much
more concerned about when it comes to
the dynamics of things so this is just
one more example but I'm out of time
basically can be smart about how you
represent geometries and then you can do
some very complex multi-phase physics
multi-material physics as a result of
that so let let's kind of wrap up so the
challenges for these multi scale physics
problems we can do a good job with the
science with good collaborations and
with good mathematics representing the
problem as best we can but a lot of
times we still introduce a lot of
uncertainty can we solve the
mathematical problem correctly most the
time yes I think every person with good
numerical training understands when to
be careful about that I think people
that use packages have a much harder
time of knowing whether they're getting
a good answer or not and the way you get
past that is with a lot of extensive
testing to make sure that you can trust
the answers coming out it's not just
looks right a lot of investments in
clever numerix and computational and and
computer resources like Newark and
scaling up the software for them for
things like adaptive mesh refinement and
computer science advances and things
like factorization and many-core and
threading we can get the calculations
done in a reasonable time
but I but I think we can never actually
get enough simulations
I think you've talked to any scientist
they just wish they could run you know
the whole computer all the time and it
would be theirs especially the quantum
chromodynamics people but I think the
lesson learned here is that we get
better and better with these things
every 10 years and the opportunities
become more and more real in terms of
what we can actually design and I think
we're getting more and more close to
kind of a real time view of modeling
reality which which is really exciting
so thank you for all your time one other
question here which was on the clip
modeling that you showed what feedback
do you get from them observational e to
help you know understand that you're
doing the right thing and so how do you
prepare a result that they produce with
your models what goes into that as much
as possible right for anyone that's done
computational models you want to get as
much data as you can this is an example
of particle image velocimetry there's a
movie that goes along with this where
you can see each of those shiny
particles getting drawn up and into the
resin so we can get a velocity field for
a particular part shape so that's an
example of something we could validate
against this test is actually something
they've done routinely to try to measure
how fast their chemical reactions happen
and so this is what they call a dot test
for this company and they actually know
if you draw a slice across in fact that
blue line was the data we sent to them
along that line you can see how that the
rate at which that reaction happens
versus time another great example but of
course you know the ultimate proof is
they have a printed part we predict a
printed part and you look at the two of
them and you say well that looks more
like a plant than a person so
okay right so it's still kind some sense
absolutely yep but building it up from
confidence from little parts is a good
way to at least build your confidence in
an end simulation any other questions so
going back to one of your requirements
the conservation requirements yes is
that conservation at each delta T or
conservation eventually you know it
always depends right just to repeat the
question for those that couldn't hear
asking about how stringent are the
conservation requirements if you're
doing shock dynamics you don't get shock
speeds correct if you do not have strict
conservation every time step every cell
that's just kind of the mathematical
nature of things if you're doing
chemistry conservation is extremely
important because it helps you eliminate
unphysical behaviors like negative
concentrations of oxygen or reactions
that don't stop when they're limited by
the amount of components that you can
put in so conservation were very strict
about it in general for things like for
that clip process for the printing
process you care about momentum
necessarily as a conserved quantity
probably not it's such a viscous gooey
thing that it disappears kinetic energy
probably don't care about it but thermal
energy because it affects the reactions
you better conserve some kind of thermal
thermal / chemical reaction energy right
so it absolutely depends on the problem
and you know my trainings not just
numerix but it's also mechanical
engineering and I've had exposure to
lots of computer science techniques I
think the best people in these fields
are ones that can bring together all
those different disciplines humbly and
ask whether - doing a good job or not
any other questions let's think cons
again thank you
[Applause]